that's our extremely agile flier during  flight they morph their wings changing  the shape of the bones and again during  different parts of the wing beat in fact  bats have more than 40 joints in their  wings in order to capture the agility in  a robot researchers created bat thoughts  based on the most important joints in  the bat wing that bot is a fully  autonomous flying robot weighing in at  93 grams and it's articulated wings are  covered in a percent fifty six microns  in remembering it also moves its legs in  order to shape the wing surface with  this design that bot is able to fly  straight dive and even make banking turn  not only is that bought a new more agile  type of aerial robot its design making  insight into how real baths use their  legs to control pitch during flight  [Music]  you